[Мішель і буйволи]
Коли я вперше приїхав в Україну,
усіх буйволиць тут звали Юлька
а всіх биків – Боря.
Але ж у нас було і до сорока буйволів,
і не можна було всіх назвати Юля і Боря.
Тож ми подумали,
що у нас є класні волонтери і ми їм кажемо:
«Добре, у тебе сьогодні народила буйволиця,
і є маленький бичок, то ти можеш придумати ім'я».
Ми класним волонтерам даємо такий шанс —
придумати власне ім'я для буйвола.
Декілька імен доволі екзотичні.
Но!
Карпатські буйволи одразу розуміють,
хто добрий до них.
Хто друг, хто старший.
Також буває бик, який агресивний
і небезпечний для людей.
Ще цей буйвол тягне віз як кінь
і дає молоко як корова, але жирніше.
[говорять німецькою]
В Україні не більше 200 буйволів.
Чайдии! Палько, куди йдеш?!..
Оппаа!..
Опа, Палько, оп!..
Оп! Оп!..
Оп!..
Но!..Но йдии, ходи сюди!..
Наша громадська організація
хоче зберегти таких буйволів,
яких легко доїти і котрі дуже розумні.
Останні роки люди допомагали
відкрити такі буйволині ферми.
Тепер в цьому регіоні збільшується
популяція наших буйволів.
Тримати буйволів це модно, це мистецтво.
Я подумав, що це загалом мистецтво —
утримувати такого травоїдного, як буйвол.
Бо він створює ландшафтний дизайн.
Цей пейзаж, в якому пасуть буйволи,
через 10-20 років стає схожим на англійський парк.
Залишаться тільки великі дуби, великі дерева
і навколо таке поле, ніби скошене.
[стукає сокирою]
Там, де люди полюбляють відпочивати,
найкращий пейзаж:
маленькі болота, ставки, річка тече,
велике гарне дерево, котре дає тінь,
трава та квіти.
Буйволи не їдять квіти.
Їдять траву, а квіти залишають.
У мене завжди багато буйволів було.
Спочатку у мене було 30 штук,
потім я продав 15 до Слобожанщини.
Потім побільшало
і я віддав 10 [буйволів] до Одеси.
Коли знову побільшало,
я ще раз віддав до заповідника до Одеси.
Я намагався порахувати,
у мене були до сто різних буйволів.
В один момент було 40.
Більше одномоментно я ще не тримав.
Опа, опа!..Оп!
Коли буйволиця потрапляє до мене
з м'ясокомбінату і вона дуже травмована,
то треба 3-4 місяці до півроку кожного
дня
проводити час, гладити, кормити.
Тоді вона більш-менш буде вірити людям.
А є такі буйволи, що ніколи не пробачають
і не люблять людей взагалі вже.
Пробував жити тепер у Німеччині,
мені не подобається.
Там гроші легше йдуть, але не має сенсу
тільки заради грошей жити.
Найкраще отак.
Я не можу лишити цих буйволів,
цих гірських корів,
поки я не буду впевнений на 100%,
що вони врятовані.
Вони не під загрозою знищення знову.
Є такі олігархи, які розуміють,
що у магазині не купиш якісної продукції.
Там або хімія, або багато антибіотиків.
Продукція від нещасних тварин
потрапляє в магазин.
Таке [як в мене] купують багатії,
котрі розуміють, що треба мати свої,
домашні, натуральні екологічні продукти.
Буйвола тримати – треба
мінімально три години на день.
Покласти новий «електровівчар»,
кормити з ясел, чистити. Це непросто.
[стукає сокирою]
Одна буйволиця дає один
кілограм моцарели на день.
А моцарела коштує
мінімум 800 гривень за кілограм.
Ви доїте дві буйволиці, але працюєте
максимум три години на день —
і маєте 1600 гривень.
Ось так легко жити у природі і мати дохід до кишені.
Люди, котрі повертаються до природи,
типу «дауншифтинг»,
котрі люблять жити правильно — їм легше.
У нас є молоді люди у Буштині,
що тримають вже 15 буйволів і пару корів,
він вирощує женьшень і може отак
більш-менш спокійно жити.
А тепер я з молока роблю гірський
сир собі, ще й і експериментую.
Я роблю масло.
Ми тепер з волонтерами та друзями
все робимо для себе та близьких.
Є у мене декілька друзів у Києві,
я їм даю добрий продукт.
Ми робимо бартер.
Один добрий друг Саша Філіпович
дав книжку «Lawrence in Arabia».
А я йому натомість — сир.
[Ukraїner]